-Our first guest tonight i
the host of the
Emmy- and Peabody-winning
"Last Week Tonight" on HBO
Welcome back to the
show John Oliver, everybody.
-Hello.
-There you are.
-Hello, Seth.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, Seth.
Hello, magical mystery door.
-I continue to be so jealous o
a choice you made early on
which was to do your show
in just front of
a white background.
-That's right. That's right.
Don't let people into your life.
And also -- Also, I am willing
to bet a great deal of money
that that flower arrangement
is not of your choosing.
That has your wife's style
written all over it.
-This is day one of
the flower arrangement.
It took her a full two weeks
to watch anything
that we had done on the
television show.
-That sounds about right, yep.
-Yeah.
And so she was aghast two week
into our remote shows
to see how poorly
dressed the set was.
-That's right. That's right.
How you look, how you're makin
your house look, collectively.
Yeah, that's why
I just go with blank.
You can't argue with nothing
-No.
And was it born out of
necessity or choice?
-Well, first, we were --
The week that
everyone started closing, we
ended up in a studio in Hoboke
and we just did it in front of
a white backdrop,
because our studio in New York
was full of coronavirus.
So, we were in front of a
white backdrop anyway,
so we thought we'd just
continue with this.
But it's
-Yeah.
-You did your
third remote show last night
How has it been for you guys
getting the show up and running?
-I guess it is only three,
right? Yeah.
When you say "three," it sound
like such a small number.
-Yeah.
-It's been alright.
You know, it's nice to be
able to see my staff,
albeit, you know,
visually, remotely.
It's not easy.
I'm not technically gifted
so there is
a very real chance that
we're going to have
one week where we get throug
the whole thing,
I send the file, and they say,
"There's nothing here"
and I say,
"Oh, that makes sense."
I think we're all surprise
it's taken this
long for that to happen.
-Well, three out of three is
an impressive start.
-That's right.
That's a hat trick.
-Yeah, you're batting a .100 -
batting a 1.000.
You were on our show
a month ago,
when there was
one case in New York City.
And, obviously,
there was a controlled panic
-When there was one recorded
case in New York City.
That's right.
I think, in hindsight,
it seems there were probably -
I don't want to say --
between 1,000 and 5,000 case
in New York at that point.
-Yeah. Yeah.
It's an interesting idea,
the one recorded,
because I think a lot of
people react to,
"Oh, it's only one,"
but, obviously,
you were correct
in assuming that it
was probably closer to 5,000
-It's been amazing to see.
I remember Ron DeSantis,
last week, saying,
"Listen, there's no point in u
having stay-at-home
orders in Florida because,
you know,
we have counties with no cases."
No, you don't.
No, you don't, Ron.
You don't have counties
with no cases.
You just don't --
We don't have enough tests
I promise you
you don't have that.
I would love it if that were the
case, but it isn't, Ron.
It isn't.
-How is your panic level
these days?
How are you doing?
-I mean, I guess give me
a scale to judge that on.
-Well, I mean,
let's say Trump --
Not panicked at all is Trump
gets blown out in the election
Most panic is
he serves four terms.
-Okay.
I am -- That's the scale.
-Yeah.
-I am I want to say about here
-Okay, gotcha.
-3 1/2 terms.
It must be -- Your wife,
a former Army combat medic
so I would assume things lik
protective gear --
she has a --
It hit close to home.
How has this, in your home
been discussed,
the just stunning lack of gear
for those on the front lines
-I guess is --
First, it's disgusting,
and then I guess
what's even sadder is
it's almost predictable,
because this is how
we fought wars in the past
My wife went to war with
ludicrously poor equipment
We were -- I went to
Afghanistan in 2013,
and they were --
We were doing a USO tour,
and I took my wife with me
And there was a -- It was
medics' van on base,
and she said, "Oh, that's mine
That's the one that
we used to drive around in."
And they said, "Oh, yeah,
we're not allowed to drive tha
on base now.
We just don't know how to
get rid of this."
They couldn't drive it aroun
to go get food
because it had canvas doors.
My wife went to war
with canvas doors.
And not in 1911.
-Right.
Yeah, 'cause I was
going to say --
-Let me just be clear.
Let me just be clear.
Age is just a number, Seth
Age is just a number,
but my wife is not
whatever that would be.